Dark Horse no let's see shot right there
right in the pocket it's up not a lot of
waste of motion that helps in this
competition
you know why he shoots like that when he
was a kid he couldn't get the ball up
there so that's where he developed that
motion
look at this fin that comes off on his
follower you see how the ball yes access
this way as opposed to over it and what
does that tell you well that's because
his wrist is shooting right now yes
I'm sweating right now oh he hit the
starry
okay
he's got that kind of range
and look his money rack is the last it's
the last wrap so he's going to be nice
and warm you got 13 already
yep two-story range boom and he still
has his money Rock left people does he
get 30.
does he get dirty shot big shot I want
them giving out money
oh we needed that one
one more we need it here it is
[Applause]
yes sir
yes sir 300 000. let's go
Dark Horse pig that's right spoke about
this on the podcast
so 31 points the great follow-through
right there which reg was talking about
Smooth Operator and it's a one-time
donation of three hundred thousand
dollars to the NBA Foundation that is
incredible for the fake All-Star yeah
absolutely amazing made six of his seven
moneyballs I didn't want to go there but
you're you're gonna draw I'm gonna drag
you in it that's right
absolutely
take that Wally absolutely
our next competitor also from the
Indiana